all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with DC's dwar of
the undead Gods part two the second part
of the final chapter of the DC story as
always if you guys are new to the
channel make sure you guys check out the
playlist down in the description so you
can get caught up so here's the thing in
the last video we basically talked about
how in effect the anti-life virus which
is sort of a stand-in for a zombie virus
to a degree that it had basically been
cured right and the efforts of the
superheroes or at least what's left of
the superheroes was to travel across the
universe and cure pretty much any of the
places that have been infected but they
don't know that like Darkseid is back
right he's still infected with the
anti-life virus and so on and so forth
so one of the things that happens right
this initially focuses on scot-free and
big Barta right Mr Miracle now for those
of you guys who don't know these guys
are what are called New Gods so the
reality here is that these folks are
wildly powerful something to know about
when it comes to New Gods is they are
all on in some way equivalent to like
Superman Wonder Woman those guys in term
terms of power they're all hugely
powerful right they're not exactly equal
and they kind of varies depending on one
person to the next but like scot-free
for example can break out of any prison
no matter what it is anywhere in the
universe and big Barta while she's just
big and she's badass right that's
basically what that is but the idea
behind this is that they had a son and
when the initial virus went off their
son was basically taken to new genesis
which is the home of the New Gods in
order to basically keep him safe right
what better place to keep him away from
the entire apocalypse than a place that
can only be accessed by those with Godly
powers and a place that is a home to
Godly beings that are easily able to
overcome virtually any Force within the
realm of DC Comics and so as a result of
that once they end up getting back there
one of the things that we saw in the
last video right at the end of the last
video was the story of Supergirl who was
just now being introduced to the story
remember like the whole idea of DC's
takes place in an alternate reality and
so what we found out with Supergirl is
unlike the main DC Universe where her
origin sees her arriving on Earth
instead she arrived on new genesis not
only that apocalypse had attacked new
genesis and basically turned virtually
everybody there into one of his
anti-life forces right kind of like a
zombie so to speak and so as soon as
Supergirl arrived she was immediately
attacked and converted and so once
scot-free and big Barta arrive here not
realizing what's going on they
immediately find that new genesis has
fallen right the new gods have basically
Fallen they don't really know exactly
what's going on they just know that
things are really bad but their
immediate concern is to look for their
son and then noticing a dark portal off
to the side big Barda initially goes to
enter and is stopped by the black racer
now for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with the black racer in DC
Comics it's one of the many allegories
of death in DC that the black racer is
just kind of this personification of the
Grim Reaper to a degree he's really the
most popular version of the Grim Reaper
but different personifications or
aspects of death exist out there but by
and large whenever the black racer
appears it is a being that simply cannot
be outran with the exception of like
Barry Allen The Flash and like that's it
and the result to this is that when it
comes to the black racer showing up here
it actually rescues big Barda now the
reason why this matters is because the
black racer despite the fact that it is
the Grim Reaper it can be killed if you
are powerful enough you can destroy the
black racer the reason why this matters
is because with the fall of new genesis
the black racer is just one of the
survivors and literally it tells them
dark side is back dark side is the
unliving god Darkseid is the one who is
controlling the entirety of all these
forces with the anti-life virus he
attacked new genesis he's bolstering his
army and it's going to spread across the
entirety of the universe unless we can
find some way to stop it and so the
first thing that Darkseid does right
after destroying new genesis and taking
it over bolstering his army with the
power of the new Gods the first main
world that exists out there in the
universe that doesn't belong to any of
the Gods the first one they attack is
karuger now for those of you guys who
are familiar with DC Comics bear with me
here for a second for those of you guys
who aren't karuger is the home planet of
thou sinestra so thalcinestro is
arguably one of the most powerful Green
Lanterns to have ever existed he
ultimately ended up becoming kind of a
dictator of his own Homeworld instead of
protecting karuger and that sector he
actually just kind of became this ruler
that that literally controlled it with
an Iron Fist and because he betrayed the
charter of the Green Lanterns he was
ultimately exiled from the Green Lantern
Corps and then formed his own core
called the Sinestro core in that where
the Green Lantern Corps feeds on
Willpower right how much gumption how
much strength you have to overcome the
odds that the Sinestro core is empowered
by fear how scared are you and the
result of this is that Peru or Falls
instantly I mean these guys never had a
chance like it's not even Sinister or
those guys who are here it's basically
just the planetary defense of karuger
but these guys don't stand a chance
against the power of of New Gods it's
like an army of Superman just descending
on this world there's nothing they can
do they never had a chance to begin with
but fortunately for them an SOS gets
shot out into space and Thal Sinestro
overhears it right now he's currently
the ruler of war world and the main DC
Universe uh war world is actually ruled
by somebody else that basically turns
into like a giant tournament World a
giant battle world where all people do
is just fight to the death but with thou
Sinestro ruling it this is where his
Sinestro core resides so we can largely
assume the reason behind the celestial
core's existence is the same here in
DC's as it is in the main DC Universe
but the the reality here and really what
he basically declares is like we are
gonna go save my homework Ruger now
under any normal Circumstance the
celestial core would never do this and
if they did they would arrive there to
feed on the fear of that world in order
to bolster their own power and that
would largely be it right these are this
is not a humanitarian peacekeeping Force
they don't do things because it's the
right thing to do that's the Green
Lantern Corps right the celestial core
just exists to bolster its own power and
so what we end up doing is that while
they respond we switch over to Superman
and we switch over to basically some of
the superheroes on Earth because
remember Brainiac had come along now
Brainiac is wildly powerful brainiac's
usually capable and Brainiac fell before
the power of Darkseid and this is really
just DC showing us how far gone Darkseid
is and the level of power that Darkseid
possesses because the on running theme
Here is that with Darkseid being
possessed by the anti-life virus then in
a lot of ways darkseid's not even in
control of his own faculties he's more
part of a hive mind if you want to call
it that than anything else but he's just
kind of the leader so to speak right
he's kind of the the one that sort of
Marshals everything and leads everything
and so it's a cool scenario because in
this case you have literally the
superheroes who are here outside of
Superman who are like why would we trust
Brainiac this guy's a bad guy this guy
literally travels Across the Universe he
basically captures entire cities and
then shrinks them down for his own
personal collection countless beings
have died because of the actions of
Brainiac why would we trust him and the
reality here is the enemy of my enemy is
my friend that's literally what it boils
down to that that dark side is the main
focus here right Darkseid is the main
bad guy here and in times of desperation
this is what it leads to that what you
have are the forces of Darkseid
spreading across the universe like a
plague and it cannot be easily stopped
that even somebody like Brainiac as
powerful as he is fell before the power
of Darkseid something to keep in mind
Brainiac is a challenge for Superman on
a good day this is the this is the kind
of being that we're looking at here
falling before a dark side in that
capacity shows us just how dire things
really are and so the result of this is
okay like this is the alliance that
we're making we're allying ourselves
with Brainiac and not only that we're
reaching out to every single being
across the universe that has not Fallen
before the power of Darkseid and they're
gonna we're all gonna become allies even
if they've just been mortal enemies over
the years even if all they've ever tried
to do is destroy us at the end of the
day saving the universe is more
important than these stupid Petty
squabbles that we have with these
various villains that exist out there
because the unifying factor that we all
share is we want to live and that's a
very powerful motivator and so what this
does is it switches back directly over
to thousinestro and this is a really
really cool moment because Val Sinestro
literally taking the power of war world
that his intention is not to destroy the
entirety of Kruger but instead to
basically start firing on those who are
possessed by the anti-life and Destroy
them the problem here is the attack is
stopped by the arrival of sironic Natsu
and Kyle Raynor now Kyle Raynor being
here is one of the cooler things right
in DC Comics Hal Jordan was like the
most popular Green Lantern for years and
years and years and then eventually DC
killed him off and they replaced him
with Kyle Rayner who arguably was
equally if not more popular but he was
the main Green Lantern for about a
decade all throughout pretty much the
mid to late 1990s and the early 2000s
until Hal Jordan was eventually brought
back as the Green Lantern by Jeff
Johnson is the daughter of thou Sinestro
now in the main DC Universe like Kyle
Rainer and sironic not to kind of had an
on-again off-again relationship until
the Robert venditti run of Green Lantern
when they basically became enemies
and there was no love lost there right
she hated Kyle Raynor because Kyle
Raynor basically ended up having to
destroy their future son and because
that was the case things just kind of
parted ways here in this universe
they're married which is really cool to
actually see that their relationship
worked out but they don't understand the
full totality of the situation as far as
they're concerned thou Sinestro is up to
his old tricks and attacking karuga
again now the funny thing about this is
thousinestro himself being so arrogant
and so full of hubris doesn't bother to
explain what it is that he's actually
doing it's just one of those things
where he's like I know better than you
two stay out of my way right I have a
bigger Mission here the problem is that
their conversation is immediately
interrupted by the arrival of Supergirl
and the reality here is remember the
anti-life virus operates with what's
basically a hive Bond and seeing the
thou Sinestro had War World at his
disposal that word world is powerful
enough to destroy the entirety of karuga
if it needs to and certainly obliterate
most of those new Gods who exist on
karuga itself and are in the process of
conquering it and so because the mother
boxes serve as much of a transportation
device as they do the ability to
transfer the virus to somebody else
Supergirl literally takes a mother box
and smashes it into war world and
because it is a technological Planet
it's overtaken by the anti-life virus
what this does is it literally turns War
World from just this controllable object
into one that works on behalf of the
anti-life virus and can now literally go
through the universe and just start
spewing the anti-life virus onto
everybody or just annihilating entire
worlds right imagine those of you guys
coming from Marvel Comics imagine that
Galactus was infected with this
anti-life virus and that's more or less
what you're looking at here in terms of
Destruction on a planetary level and the
ability to spread that destruction over
a rapid amount of time and so with Kyle
weiner being knocked out with archilo
who is really one of the more popular
members of the Sinestro 4 being
destroyed it really just comes down to
thousinestro and sironic Natsu the
problem with this is Darkseid makes his
move and dark side emerges onto the
scene now initially and the way that
we're told is like you have Sinestro and
you have his daughter basically a Yellow
Lantern and a Green Lantern fighting
side by side and there is equilibrium
and in fact they're an even match for
the power of of Darkseid and his Omega
beams and they're actually holding him
off the problem is what little
equilibrium existed here is immediately
nullified when Supergirl goes back on
the offense and literally gives the
upper hand to dark side and when that
happens Darkseid immediately sees his
thou Sinestro and in these dying moments
and probably what's just one of the
greatest moments of thousandestro
garments it's finale the way this ends
is amazing so in one of these like like
these these kind of dying moments of
Sinestro he literally tells saronic you
have to run right you have to get out of
here you have to live so that you can
free karuger you have to find allies
people who can fight on our side and
people who can ensure the survival of
the universe only you can protect this
world and in that moment as soon as done
saying that Darkseid kills Sinestro by
ripping his head off and literally all
that can happen here Kyle Wainer is just
like we have to go we can't stay here if
we stay we die like this guy killed
Sinestro Sinestro is more powerful than
we are there's no way we can overcome
this force and so with Kyle Raynor and
sironic natu doing the only thing they
can do which is to just Flee for their
lives and then try to find some measure
of allies that exists out there most
likely Superman and the the existing
Justice League that what this does is it
switches back to dark side and with
thousand nestro having died as you guys
know when a lantern dies as long as the
ring is not destroyed it searches for a
new replacement and that's exactly what
the ring does right ring status report
Sinestro 1 deceased scan for replacement
sentient initiated scan for replacement
and then it immediately goes to dark
side and it's like you have the ability
to instill great fear welcome to the
Sinestro core and dark side officially
becomes a yellow lantern with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end I told you this thing was
legit thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later peace